first of all congrats um i have the best
compliment i can give you is that i
watch a lot of things
and i truly did not see
some of the twists and turns that we're
gonna i don't want to get specific but
there were some twists and turns i
absolutely did not see coming
wow that's uh that's a big compliment
coming from you man i know you're
embedded into this space uh you
definitely do your homework and due
diligence before these conversations so
any compliment coming from you is always
taken and uh appreciated you know i'm a
i'm a fan i'm a fan of of you and your
breakdowns throughout the years
i'm just gonna say uh right back at you
um what so did you actually come up with
kids last name or it was never on the
table
well the beauty of what we did we didn't
want to give them a name at all
we wanted to to really have like a mind
melt moment for the audience right
because you're you're having a moment
where you see similarities in kids life
in the beginning stages of his career
and my career right and the fact that
you never refer to him as a name you
have the assumption that it's kevin hart
until the twist and turn until it gets
dark until it goes down that that dark
alley and that journey that we
eventually take you on you realize that
kevin's acting and he's playing the
character but in the beginning you know
when you watch it it's like okay wait
this is kevin hart and his kim heart's
life so that was the whole idea behind
kid you know not giving him a name it's
a nickname he doesn't have a first name
or last name they call him kid so how
much of this is kevin and how much of
this is a character how much of this is
his life and how much of it is made up
you know that was the idea um just from
an artistic approach
one of the things is that um you've been
famous for a little while now man and uh
i don't think no one goes to school to
learn how to be famous you gotta
you have to learn it on the fly i mean
i'm not famous i can only imagine what
you go through on a daily basis can you
sort of talk about because i think it
does the show does a very good job at
pulling like the the curtain behind at
letting you see what it's really like
behind the scenes how much is that
actually
what it's like for you you know what i
mean
you know i mean look that was the that
was the beauty of working with uh eric
newman you know um you know for those
who don't know his background he's a
creator behind narcos you know writer on
that show as well um it was making sure
we ground
our our idea the the concept behind the
idea and that was the
the the feeling in the mind the mindset
of kid and when you talk about fame you
talk about success you know there's a
constant compromise of time
understanding and feeling um and comfort
right it's it's always it's always a
push for more and there's never an
understanding of less so from the
celebrity perspective um if you complain
well how dare you because you have it
all uh if you have a problem how dare
you because you're perceived to have it
all um and kid's case you know his
problems as they start to to to rise you
see that his his his temper his patience
it gets shorter and and the things that
he once had understanding for he slowly
starts to lose it and people are getting
snapped on um that that that fuse is is
burning at an unbelievable pace so it
was it was creating real moments right
those those real moments the the the
stalker fan um you know the surroundings
uh of your of your your your people that
work underneath this umbrella that
you've created and the job that they do
and how hard that job is at times when
dealing with you on your on or off day
the scheduling um the immediate shutdown
of the performance side of it um there's
so much that goes into the machine that
moves so we wanted to try to pull the
curtain back and show as much as we
could
i already got a rap i'm just gonna say
you know it goes [ __ ] quick i'll just
say man really enjoyed it um and uh wish
you nothing but the best
thank you man i can't wait to talk to
you again uh a lot of stuff of course
coming down the pipeline but this is uh
this is my baby this is the one that i'm
so excited about and this is the
opportunity for me to allow the world to
see me in a different light
well that yeah that's the thing i wanted
to say but for next time it's just it's
a completely different performance for
you and um i really enjoyed it you know
i gotta go
you